[Musik]
das podcast ist platin blm unic woche
angekündigt meine daumen das habe
eigentlich verdeckt
fangen wir aber kommen wir jetzt heute
eine lenkerin und vielleicht philosophen
sie müssen wie immer ihre eigene meinung
drachen namens margaret thatcher also
sehr hübsch margareta also marktplatz
und sie ist tatsächlich eine frau die
hingerichtet würde ihr habt gerade weil
ich sowieso die sind diese vorlesung
schreiben müsste habe ich auch die
podcast folge dazu geschrieben und ihr
habt damit an mit der frage angefangen
wäre der mittelalterliche soccer tees
sein könnte wirklich sagt ja also alle
die schola sticker machen klose fiel
ganz gerne in form von fragen und
antworten zur passion ist destatis
also die man könnte sagen die sind alle
drei sind diesen alle erfassung von
socket ist oder man könnte zum beispiel
roger bacon nehmen wer wie ich mal sagen
werde ins gefängnis gekommen ist aber
die einzige die wirklich für philosophie
oder mindestens theologie für ihre
philosophischen ansichten gestorben ist
wie sorge dies war margareta ports
interessanterweise ist dich die
spätantike fassung von sokratis ist auch
weiblich weil das wäre
martina der der hauptfigur in einem
dialog über unsterblichkeit der seele
ist wo sie wirklich über dieses thema
gleich vor dem tod spricht das den text
haben wir schon besprochen der die
antike also klassische antike fast
konstant partie ist wahr aber männlich
sagte titz
das war ein witz nochmal der klassisch
anti der klassische antike sorge dies
war männlich nämlich socket hieß sind
die witze dann passe man sich ja das war
das problem der wind ist durch geplatzt
deswegen haben sie hat niemand es
verstanden das ist meine austreten weil
also weil ihr leben in dieser tage
hinweise beendet hat dachte ich dass ich
als ein bisschen zusammenhang und
kontext zuerst etwas allgemeines zensur
und philosophie mit leute sagen könnte
das sind natürlich an sich interessant
und ist nicht unwichtig für unser thema
im allgemeinen
denn wir gesehen haben dass viele von
denen frauen die mittelalter
philosophisch oder philosophisch
ähnliche werke geschrieben haben
die haben sie haben ziemlich gewagte
ideen gehabt und es was wirklich
interessant ist ist zu betrachten dass
zum beispiel hildegard von bingen
obwohl sie schon probleme mit der kirche
hatte dass das war wirklich so sagen
interne streit über macht und bestimmte
entscheidungen innerhalb kirchlichen
autorität
sie war nonne und gehörte zu dem
kirchlichen struktur und sie ist
deswegen sehr weit weg zum beispiel von
margarita die wirklich eine unabhängige
lenkerin ist völlig außerhalb
der kirche kritisiert so deutlich her
hält oder also nicht kritisiert aber
beleidigt mehr oder weniger die kirche
wie dann später wenn werde
nennen sie die die örtliche kirche die
kirche im klein und die zellen die gott
erreichen das sind die sind die kirche
in groß also es offensichtlich
beleidigend und ich bleibe ich denke
wahrscheinlich absichtlich beleidigend
und das ist wieder ein beispiel von dem
was wir sehr oft gesehen haben dass
selbst frauen die ähnliche ideen hatten
zum teil sehr anders voneinander sind
intensiv den den historischen
zusammenhang und auch wie sie unter
zeitgenössischen angekommen sind sehr
sehr kontrovers sogar hingerichtet
billiger als sehr beliebt in ihrem in
der zeit wo sie gelebt hat und in der
mitte jemand wie zum beispiel die den
beginn mystikerinnen die wir letzte
woche besprochen haben also etwas
kontrovers aber haben kein kein großes
ärger dafür gekriegt
ok also wahrscheinlich wenn sie ein
mittelalter denken denken sie nicht aber
das war eine blütezeit für freies denken
in der menschlichen geschichte
im gegenteil war dass wenn dann die zeit
in der in der geschichte philosophie wo
man am wenigsten freiheit hatte die
eigene ideen zu äußern bzw
überhaupt frei zu denken oder eine ideen
zu haben
2 jeder vor allem sie dann in büchern
und zu schreiben
das ist natürlich ein vorurteil
und wie viele vorteile entspricht nicht
unbedingt die historische situationen
ich würde sagen dass man im modernen
europa vielleicht beste beispiele finden
krank kann von sensor- und und
verurteilung als in vor allem in den
frühen mittelalter also wenn man zum
beispiel spinoza ein spieler denkt und
was ihm passiert ist und dann denkt man
okay einen ähnlichen philosophie im
frühmittelalter finden da tut man sich
schwer
nichts dass es sozusagen alles offen war
und es gab auch theologisch ich schreite
streit es gab fälle wo banker für ihre
theologische theologische ansichten beim
ins gefängnis gekommen würden oder
häufiger dass die bücher verbrannt
würden also war sozusagen nichts
wirklich anything goes aber sie wollten
nichts nichts so vielleicht nicht so
formuliert und auch vor allem nicht so
gefährlich wie es dann ab dem
dreizehnten jahrhundert geworden ist und
an hier können wir vielleicht zu einem
ereignis deuten was ich schon mehrmals
erwähnt habe nämlich der kreuz der kreuz
war gegen die katarer in südfrankreich
schon in der ersten phase dieser dieses
kriegs und versuchen irgendwie unter
kontrolle bringen haben wir die erste
fälle wo angeblich christliche personen
hingerichtet werden wegen ihren
ansichten dessen natürlich kann er
philosophische ansichten und im
allgemeinen war es nicht so dass mit dem
philosophen mix normalerweise mit tod
bedroht wurden
er hat
sie das problem dass sie zum beispiel
aus der universität fliegen würden oder
dass die bücher verbrannt würden dass
die bücher verbrannt werden kann könnten
und sie könnten dann vor gericht gezogen
werden und dass das wäre die solche
solche probleme würde dann vorkommen je
nachdem was der gerichte entscheiden
würde
es war auch möglich dass intellektuelle
dann ins gefängnis kommen könnte könnten
und ein eine gewisse vorahnung davon
haben wir schon im zwölften jahrhundert
mit einem sehr berühmte philosoph den
wir schon erwähnt haben der boyfriend
von alois peter schappeler dass der
wegen seinen theologischen ansichten
dienst ins gefängnis gekommen ist aber
sondern es vor einem prozess gestand
würde und seine ideen würden mehr oder
weniger abgelenkt oder verboten
man hat versucht beim papst nachzufragen
ob das ob sie das ob die entscheidung
dann vielleicht wieder abgelehnt werden
könnte von seite der papst war nicht
erfolgreich
und also hat sozusagen verloren in
diesem kampf interessanterweise schreibt
ja aber einfach weitere werke wo er mehr
oder weniger das gleiche sagt also man
man hat den eindruck dass das die
situation für ihn noch mal hier ist
vielleicht wichtig dass die
universitäten noch nicht da sind
also was man in allen diesen kleinen
schulen dann gelernt hat es war
vielleicht ein bisschen offener und
vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger für
die aktualitäten nachzuvollziehen wer
was sagt und wo
immerhin haben wir schon in solchen
jahrhunderts diese vorwarnung von dem
was in der in den 13 jahrhundert
passiert
interessanterweise stellte sich heraus
dass in kreisen jahrhundert also das
erste was man woran man hier denkt ist
alles dort ließ alles drin ist kommt
rein wird völlig überschätzt
viele ideen also dass dies sehr
kontrovers bzw
vielleicht sogar als ketzerisch
verurteilt zb ewigkeit der welt und ganz
am anfang des 13
jahrhunderts gibt es versuche die werke
des ortes zu verbannen weil sie nichts
zu erlauben dass sie an der universität
in paris unterrichtet werden
aber das war relativ also über die
kürzere zeit und war über die längere
zeit
es war wie ist dieses versuch völlig
gescheitert zuerst haben manche so las
ich einfach an wie die universitäten
gesucht zb in england wo sie die volle
die volle palette von werke dass der
werke das alles lesen konnten
erstens zweitens haben sie anscheinend
weiterhin hat es gelesen werke die
verwandt wurden vielleicht nicht
unterrichtet aber dann kommt es immer
mehr und mehr in unterricht rhein und
bis mitte seiten jahrhundert haben wir
die umgekehrte situation wo die werke
als als lotte ließ alle pflicht texte
sind für die eskalation für die schola
sticker also das heißt alle in späten
zweiten jahrhundert kann man davon
ausgehen dass alle gut ausgebildete
philosophen und theologen an der an den
universitäten
das auto ist sehr sehr gut kennen
trotzdem oder vielleicht sogar deswegen
haben wir ein gewisser gipfel der sensor
gerade dann im späten 13 minuten
deswegen weil also meine idee ist nach
dem alles wirklich reinkommt und
akzeptiert wird dann ist die frage wie
soll man ihn auslegen und wie weit man
soll man ihm folgen also die die kirche
hat ihnen jetzt sagen akzeptiert etwas
ungern akzeptiert als basis für die
ganze ausbildung an der uni aber ist
natürlich akzeptieren sie nicht alle
ansichten oder thesen die es zu finden
sind ehrlichkeit der welt nochmal ist
die das beste beispiel
aber je nachdem wie alt der sorte lisa
ausgelesen wird könnte konnte man damals
behaupten dass zum beispiel hat es dort
ließ der ansicht war das ist nur ein
geist für die für die ganze menschheit
existiert das ist das berühmte auslegung
von der anima das alles dort ließ also
es war der einsicht dass das dass der
intellekt passiv und aktiv nur eins ist
für alle menschen waren alle die also
sagen jeweils eine seele und diese hat
ihren sitz im menschlichen körper
aber wenn wir wirklich denken also würde
mit meinem denken zu tun haben dann
haben wir anschluss an einen internen
intellekt der von uns irgendwie getrennt
ist und vor allem uns bei allen gemein
ist also wir teilen diesen einen
intellekt natürlich könnte ich eine
ganze vorlesung darüber halten aber das
wollen sie nicht für ein paar als
männlich war
aber an diese these hat war sehr sehr
kontrovers und schienen zum beispiel
auferstehung nach dem tod zu verleugnen
und deswegen sind viele klassiker sehr
kritisch da dagegen gewesen zb thomas
von aquin hat einen text geschrieben
gegen diese auslegung des als links
wohlgemerkt was er hier kritisiert ist
nicht alles dort ließ sondern eine
arabische auslegung des art ließ und
sein buch geht eigentlich nach nicht
darum zu beweisen dass die these falsch
ist es sagt der erstens bei der ersten
seite sagt ja mehr oder weniger realität
ist offensichtlich falsch das ist doch
blödsinn
diese idee dass wir alle nur einen
intellekt haben also das ist eine
interessante frage
die interessante und schwierige frage
ist ob das deutlich dass diese blöd
anstellt einstellung hatte also auch
dass seine these wirklich war und
deswegen ist ein buch gegen nazis und
die sogenannte fr osten ist ein versuch
zu beweisen dass dieses text nicht so
ausgelegen werden kann
also man kann sagen dass er hier
versucht hat als ort ließ von der art
des todes teil i khas zu retten
also versucht zu zeigen dass alles okay
ist er war es der christlichen religion
als manche interpreten vor allem alvarez
und seine seine anhänger 1-sieger vom
verband er heute zeigen dass sie alles
falsch lesen da nichts nur um die these
zu widerlegen sondern eigentlich erst
ließ zu sichern als zuverlässiger für
das auf den man als christ wirklich im
weiterhin nutzen kann
also irgendwie ist diese versuche ihnen
christlicher auszudenken sozusagen ein
versuch hattest du technisch zu bleiben
weil man in diesem zusammenhang wenn man
christliche glaube auf einer seite hat
und alles orte wie so oft einen anderen
seite und man gibt zu dass sie
gegeneinander streiten wir wissen schon
wer gewinnen wird nicht alles dort geht
es im gegensatz dazu waren die
sogenannte am wärmsten sein wollte was
thomas schon benutzt manchmal sagt man
in der jetzigen situation bestens also
radikalste tätig und sie wollten dafür
die einzig plädieren dass man alles so
theoretische philosophie eigentlich
unabhängig von der religion dann
erforschen kann und wenn es scheint dass
alles in die falsche richtung geführt
sondern ihn einfach nicht folgen
aber man soll auch so sein für die idee
offen sein dass alles ab und so falsch
oder vielleicht nicht fall spielt aber
ein brandmal sind seine ansichten
einfach nichts mit der christlichen
religion vereinbar
und dann soll man natürlich nicht alles
glauben
man soll zu geben dass philosophie
sozusagen eine interne logik vielleicht
hat interne ansichten die einfach nichts
mit religion vereinbar sind und das ist
irgendwie okay weil vielleicht die
religion der flosse wegen überlegen ist
paradebeispiele sind diese zwei
sogenannte terroristen boys von daher
muss die sieger von brabant und sie
behaupten zum beispiel dass wenn man in
der natur für lose wie die argumente
betrachtet ob die welt ewig ist oder
nicht konnte man kommt man sehr lang
mindestens
oder sehr wahrscheinlich zu dem schluss
dass die welt ewig ist natürlich ist die
seite nicht ewig das wollen wir nicht
sagen also was wir sagen ist das wenn
man innerhalb der natur viel los wie
bleibt man könnte mit den mitteln dieser
beschränkten hat von philosophie
beweisen dass die welt ewig ist warum
weil zum beispiel in der natur
philosophie und was sind wir zugeben
dass alle ursachen vorliegende materie
brauchen und das heißt wenn die
entstehung der welt ein natürlicher
prozess ist dann brauchen wir
vorliegende materie bevor die welt
existiert also das heißt wir brauchen
mehr tiere vor weltlichen materie also
mindestens muss materie ewig sein wenn
nicht die welt wie wir sie sehen und das
ist natürlich gegen die christliche
glaube die kreation ex akzeptiert also
geschaffen hast nichts wie löst man das
ja man sagt einfach natürlich
philosophie hat nicht das letzte wort
mit diesem thema weil diese art
philosophie kranken darf nicht
anerkennen dass manche ursachen max nilo
verursachen können
das wäre keine natürliche sache das wäre
eine göttliche ursache also wenn
göttliche ursachen dann ins spiel kommen
sind wir nicht mehr innerhalb der natur
floss wie wir sind innerhalb theologie
oder vielleicht weiter physik aber
wahrscheinlich theologie und das ist
alles kein problem was mit man muss nur
zugeben dass es gewisse einschränkungen
gibt
wieweit naturphilosophie dann gehen kann
und dann zum beispiel thomas reagiert
darauf indem er sagt nein das alles
falsch du kannst das nicht beweisen weil
du kannst nichts innerhalb der
philosophie beweisen was falsch ist es
immer richtig
das heißt nicht dass wir alles beweisen
zum beispiel viele wie kann nicht die
talent beweisen aber wenn schüler sowie
irgendwas irgendwie beweisen kann dann
nur die wahrheit so viel aus wie es
immer war es auch irgendwie auch
eingeschränkt weil es kann nicht alle
wahrheiten beweisen aber wenn die fluss
wie was beweist dann nur die wahrheit
und interessanterweise könnte man sagen
das ist dass es geht weiter in die
richtung flow sowie zu schützen als die
realisten tun denn halt thomas würde
sagen du hast mir hat immer recht die
arena westen anscheinend nicht obwohl
sie angeblich radikaler sind als bewusst
philosophen okay wie sie sich vorstellen
können hat ankamen andere reaktionen
gegen diese einstellung die schärfe
waren als das was thomas tut nämlich
mehrere verurteilungen waren zwei runden
von verurteilungen sozusagen ins 570 und
1277 und dass das gehört zu den
berühmtesten ereignissen in der
mittelalterlichen philosophie geschichte
nochmal könnte ich sehr lange darüber
reden aber ich wollte ihn nur nur kurz
weg würde nur kurz schildern was
passiert ist weil sie dann einen
eindruck gewinnen können was was
geschieht im mittelalter wenn jemand
angeblich was sagt was ketzerisch ist
oder was zu weit geht
zum beispiel also ins 12 70 haben wir
nur zehn thesen die verurteilt sind und
diese thesen den verband zum beispiel
ewigkeit der welt ist ist auf der liste
von 0 77 gibt es glaube ich 291 thesen
die verbannt werden und die thesen sind
zum teil sehr sehr abstrus zum beispiel
in einer art kann nur eine sex ist
existieren wenn keine materie vorhanden
ist also zum beispiel wenn ein mensch
keine nichts aus materie bestehen würde
könnte es nur einen menschen oder anders
herum gesagt damit man mehrere einzelne
sachen und auch innerhalb einer art hat
also mehrere menschen braucht man mit
der wallonie materie könnte man die
menschen von einer der nicht
unterscheiden
also das heißt der grund war für wir 90
oder wie auch immer viele menschen wir
sind ist weil wir eine natur haben aber
viele viele körper oder viele viele
instanzen der materie und diese materie
unterscheidet uns voneinander
jetzt dürfen sie sich fragen wer in der
kirche würde denken dass muss man das
muss man akzeptieren diese these also
die these die man akzeptieren muss
ist gott kann zwei sachen ohne materie
machen die in der gleichen art sind also
zum beispiel nicht nicht nur zum
beispiel sonnen des koran wir denken wir
denken an hängen also gott kann zwei
engel produzieren die gleich sind nach
der art und nach der natur obwohl engel
keine materie haben und ihr müsst das
glauben wenn ihr christen sein wollt was
er sagt oder ein dass gott elektrizität
ist dass jesus die verkörperung gottes
war okay das sind irgendwie die
grundregeln aber das eben das verstehen
die meisten gläubigen nicht einmal
schweigen davon sie müssen das
akzeptieren damit sie okay also was das
passiert hier also grob gesagt als ist
dieses beispiel viele andere beispiele
auf der liste
sie sehr sehr detaillierte thesen die
nur innerhalb des des kontextes der
schola zwischen floss wie vor kommen
würden
also das ist nicht als ob man in der
straße in paris diskutiert wie wie gott
erschaffen kann oder nicht kann
das ist nicht dein trainer in der kneipe
in paris zwei davon außerhalb von paris
also erstens dass ein zweiter gedanke
dahinter scheint das zu sein dass man
nichts die all mächtigkeit gott gottes
einschränken will
also die der es wenn eine schola sticker
der herkommt und sagt gott kann nur zwei
henkern keinen nicht zwei engel in einer
art produzieren oder schaffen weil
materie das prinzip der individuation
ist wie wir jetzt also materie ist das
wohl dort wird die substanzen
unterscheiden wenn ein so was hier das
behauptet dann verneint er die
allmächtigen gottes und das ist schlecht
also sagen ist symptom für eine einen
versuch philosophie zu benutzen um die
allmächtigen gottes einzuschenken
interessanterweise wer hat diese these
vertreten dass man jetzt unbedingt meint
er gebraucht um 1 in sachen innerhalb
einer art zu unterscheiden
von wem ist dass die these designer aber
im zweiten jahrhundert von bmw ist die
these nichts sie vom verband nicht
projektes von daher thomas von aquin und
es gibt andere thesen auf der liste die
gleich gegen thomas gerichtet sind
diese verurteilung würde auch drei tage
zum tag nach dem tod von thomas
veröffentlicht
das heißt genau drei jahre nachdem er
gestorben ist interessant also wir haben
keine beweise dass das gegen thomas
gerichtet würde
aber viele forscher denken dass das der
fall war
andererseits hat thomas nie wirklich
direkt ärger gekriegt andere schon zum
beispiel ein oder zwei seiten offen
johannes petz als olive und waschbecken
sind hatten beide probleme wo ihre
thesen dann attackiert würden von der
kirche welten kam sogar ins gefängnis
die vorher erwähnt habe später welchem
von orkan hatte seine lehre auch in
frack hat seine lehre würde auch in
frage gestellt und seine thesen würden
oder marke von 200.000 würden auch für
euch halt aber zum glück schon gestorben
wenn man das als glück bezeichnen kann
also er hat sozusagen nicht erlebt dass
herr verurteilt war
es kam schon vor dass philosophen für
philosophische thesen verurteilt worden
interessante frage werde vielleicht
deswegen welche einfluss das auf der
philosophie hatte und sich also das
sieht welche einfluss sollte das haben
und hat dass die gewünschte wirkung
gehabt
manche interpreten tapeten von care gmbh
haben behauptet dass die wirkung also
die langfristige wirkung der
verurteilung war sehr ironische weise
das geburt der modernen wissenschaft
wieso also erstens sagen dass nahe weil
wir auch vielleicht ein bisschen richtig
wenn theologie sehr gefährlich wird und
vor allem wenn frei denken in hat der
theologie sehr gefällt wird dann kern
die freidenker weg von der theologie und
machen was geschieht ist nämlich
wissenschaft und er sieht sie für sie
verschwenden ihre zeit nicht mit
qualität und und und sondern vermeiden
diese
die themen und diskutieren wie
bewegungen funktioniert oder schwerkraft
des sommers
das ist natürlich sehr sehr naiv aber
vielleicht so ein bisschen was dran aber
wir können besser tun und bestimmt die
beispiele geben
es gibt es noch mal eine these die er
glaubt man fast nichts was wofür die
kirche bereit war
dahinter zu stehen als pflicht glaube es
ist nicht erlaubt zu behaupten dass gott
das universum nicht links rückt nach
links rutschen kann
also du darfst nicht behaupten dass gott
die die der welt also das wäre es das
universum natürlich eine sphäre für
diese leute ja sogar man es werde
und gott kann nicht laut dieser
verbannten these denn diese dieses werde
ein bisschen bewegen bewegung setzen und
das problem ist nicht dass wir alles so
gehen würden das problem ist eine
wissenschaft ein wissenschaftliches
problem nämlich was was werdet ihr was
müsste der fall sein damit gott das
machen kann
natürlich denn wenn das universum zum
beispiel zwei meter nach links oder
längst ist bleibt hat hier vielleicht
keine bedeutung
zwei meter nach oben also vom nordpol
weg vom universum war wieso kann gott
das nicht machen weil um das zu machen
brauchen wir lehrer leeres raum wo rein
des universums hin bewegen könnte aber
jeder der sorte ließ gelesen hat weiß
dass lebensraum unmöglich ist
der br hat beweise dagegen es gibt kein
vakuum in der ästhetischen wissenschaft
und deswegen angeblich haben manche
philosophen verneint dass gott das
machen kann ja auch mal kommen diese
theologen zurück von der von dem bischof
von natalies zusammengeführt
sie sagen nein das darfst du nicht
behaupten weil noch mal die an
mächtigkeit gottes die ihr diese natur
für solche überlegungen trumpft und du
kannst also für alles was gott machen
kann
vielleicht machen könnte kannst du nicht
behaupten dass er das nicht machen kann
ist wahrscheinlich das einzige was du
was gott nicht machen kann ist wirklich
eine wieder lag eines selbst widerlegung
klären
ok dann gehen wir ein bisschen nach
vorne ist im 14 jahrhundert wir finden
dann scola sticker die explizit
behaupten das vakuum existieren kann
also sie argumentieren
vielleicht denken sie irgendwie im
hinterkopf und dieses argument wird
sogar ausdrücklich gemacht wenn gott
allmächtig ist dann kann er alles tun
was kein logisches widerspruch kreiert
deswegen müsst ihr das universum zwei
meter nach links
die bewegung setzen können deswegen
müsse es möglich sein die idee und die
haben glückliche resultat die haben
recht warum es doch möglich und im
allgemeinen an war ein vorschlag in der
sakristei seine vorstellung der seiten
der netzwerke im allgemeinen würden
wissenschaftler von der von der
ästhetischen wissenschaft entfesselt
weil diese verurteilungen die viele der
grundthesen der aristotelischen physik
dann praktisch weg geschaffen haben
interessante hypothese
also man sieht hier dass das im 14
jahrhundert philosoph also im 13
jahrhundert sind sie alle
zwischendrin in dieser krise im 14
jahrhundert hat man den aktiven so
vertreten zurück und sagen okay was
können wir noch sagen
im rahmen im erlaubten rahmen also im
freien raum was von dieser verurteilung
dann noch übrig geblieben ist
und meiner meinung nach können wir dann
deswegen sagen dass margarete projekt
zum teil sehr interessant ist weil sie
nicht so reagiert vielleicht nochmal
weil sie nicht innerhalb diese diese
sind diesem universität diesem
universitätsleben ist es ist nichts an
der uni ist ist sie es so sagen ein
klassisches beispiel für einen freier
denker als die schola sticker die im
rahmen der verurteilung vorsichtig sein
müssen was sie sagen was sie nicht sagen
hier ist wie ich bald sein werde völlig
bewusst dass das was sie zu sagen hat
vielleicht kontrovers ist aber das ist
ihr eigentlich egal wie fürst hin wenn
man tut sich schwer handel denke in 14
jahre runde zu finden die so zur radikal
vorgehen
obwohl sie wissen dass sie vielleicht
dafür ärger kriegen es ist das
unterscheidet sie von dieser klassischen
welt übrigens an gab es auch in dieser
zeit und das hängt wahrscheinlich
zusammen
auch verurteilungen und verwarnungen
gegen nicht nur für das philosophische
bewegungen zb dieses radikales
sozialismus sondern auch in brighton
dessen spirituelle bewegungen eines
licht einschließlich unsere lieblinge
spirituelle bewegung nämlich die
hygienische bewegung in 214 in vienne
122 112 min 2
da ist 112 in vienne und das ist nichts
das ist nicht mein versuch vienna also
wien ins deutsche zu übersetzen das ist
eine stadt in frankreich
also wie ein mithin würden die beginnen
verurteilt und danach sterben sie mit
diesem nicht aus aber die werden die
werden deutlich weniger
und da sieht man dass die kirche doch
natürlich einen starken einfluss hat
sogar auf die möglichkeiten für frauen
innerhalb der philosophie zu treiben
nächste woche werden wir julian von
deutsch sprechen und es ist interessant
zu sehen dass sie keine keine bediener
erst sondern ein an kredite wie wir sein
werden
das passt zu einer bis zu einer breiten
entwicklung wo verschiedene spirituelle
bewegungen kontrovers geworden sind habe
schon die katharer erwähnt dass
natürlich die das ist natürlich die die
fassung davon wo man wirklich mit vollem
gewalt dagegen agiert die beginnen
so kamen dubios vor für die qualitäten
würden zuerst akzeptieren dann haben sie
um gedacht
sie ist vielleicht so gefährlich dass
diese fragen so rumrennen und dann dann
gibt es fälle wo innerhalb der struktur
der kirche man verschiedene bewegungen
hatte die auch als schwierig das sein
wird
aber nie verbannt wurden hier sind die
beste beispiel meiner meinung nach die
prediger worden also die franziskaner
die dominikaner und handeln
er ist trägt das wirklich übrigens sehr
interessant für die geschichte der
philosophie mit leute weil so viele
philosophen entweder franziskaner oder
die amerikaner waren also thomas von
aquin albertus magnus sind
dominikanerklosters und trocken zum
beispiel waren franziska das ist alles
auch die vielleicht relevanz für
margareta projekts weil sie vielleicht
eine beginn war die dokumente die wir
über ihren prozess haben nennen sie eine
beginne und es gibt auch andere zeuge
aus der zeit diebe hatten dass sie eine
beginne war aber manche von den jetzigen
forscher bezweifeln das und denken sie
jetzt sie dachten okay sie ist eine frau
sie ist so unabhängig von uns und
deswegen ist sie eine bediene aber das
heißt nicht dass sie wirklich innerhalb
diese bewegung mit beteiligt war das ist
ich glaube dass eine offene frage und
vielleicht sogar eine frage die wir
nicht beantworten können
aber sie werden vielleicht ab und zu
lesen dass ich eine beginne fraglich
also jetzt komm ich zu margarete selbst
aber freut mich dass sie bevor wir sie
besprechen hat jemand fragen zu diesem
allgemeinen thema also sensor und
verbannen und verwaltung im mittelalter
bis man sie habe ich fast alles was ich
darüber weiß schon gesagt aber etwas
nehmen könnt ihr versuchen weitere
fragen zu beantworten
ok fangen wir mit der hinrichten an das
ist zwar geschichte gefangen am ende das
am ersten juni 1310 leider mein
hochzeitstag
und das kam so sagen nicht aus heiterem
himmel sondern würde sie mehrere jahre
davor kam sie so hat die aufmerksamkeit
des bischofs bekommen wo sie gelebt hat
und der bischof hat ihr hat er ist also
irgendwie ist ihr buch zu ihm gekommen
er hat das buch gelesen oder vielleicht
hat er nur auszüge des buches gelesen
hat gedacht auch das dürfen wir nicht
erlauben
margareta wird reingeholt das buch wird
vor ihren augen verbrannt heftig und sie
würde gewarnt so sagen
die dardenne also sieht sie darf das
nicht weiter die solche ideen nicht
weiter die sanieren
und was macht sie
sie macht genau das was sie mich nicht
machen sollte sie war wahrscheinlich
weil haben das können wir dafür aus der
tatsache entnehmen dass sie mehrere
kopien ihres buches dann an mehrere
leute geschickt haben sogar antriebe
schöpfe sehr gut
das hat es mit wohlhabenden zu tun
kopien eines buches sind natürlich im
mittelalter sehr sehr teuer
also wenn du sagst ok will von kopien
meines buches haben das heißt dass du
reich bist weil du musst dann eine
scheibe wochenlang anstellen können
normal diese kopieren dann zu schauen
dass die die stoffliche zutaten eines
buches das ist alles auf haben tierhaut
es ist nicht so nicht ohne ein buch zu
machen
also wir gehen davon aus dass sie
relativ reich war hat
hat ihr buch dann an mehreren
hoffentlich anhänger geschickt wurden
nochmals die aufmerksamkeit auf sich
gezogen
gehen 1308 wurde sie verhaftet der
irgendwie sie tor
dieses will herrn von paris von paris
und er ist er zu ihr gegangen und hat
gesagt okay jetzt musst wir wir machen
jetzt prozess du musst auf den wecker
ist schön dass du die wahrheit sagen
wirst und dann sagt sie nein das mache
ich nichts ich werde ich werde
teilnehmen an diesem prozess ich erkenne
das nicht an weniger und erwartet fragt
noch mal das sieht vor sich hin
eineinhalb jahren sitzt sie im gefängnis
am ende entscheidet hat sich dass sie
nicht mitmachen wird also diese halle
die bedrohungen und so dass der markt
funktioniere nicht und deswegen kommt ja
dann eine gruppe von 21 theologen eine
schola sticker aus paris sie lesen
natürlich nicht das ganze buch sondern
nur auszüge des buches das ist übrigens
sehr typisch für mittelalterliche
prozesse und also das kann man sie
natürlich ist das alles furchtbar dass
ihr das gemacht haben aber ich glaube
sogar die internen logik ist irgendwie
kommt mir irgendwie verkehrt was sie
verbannen und vorurteilen bücher ohne
die ganze bücher zu lesen sie nehmen
sätze raus die helvetische sätze sind
angeblich und verurteilen diese sätze
und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt wenn sie
das ganze buch gelesen hätten in diesem
fall als nicht geholfen
noch schlimmer gewesen aber immerhin zum
beispiel wenn wenn 1 klassiker these
schreibt und dann erklärungen der these
sind sie völlig bereits die erklärung zu
ignorieren und einfach die these so sei
es schwarz auf weiß nehmen das als
beweis von catcher reisen also nichts
nicht sehr gut wir sind alle gegen
mittelalterliche verbrennungen
verurteilen oder das da auf seinen
verein nicht gut gehen weil diese
theologen haben sich dann entschlossen
das margareta doch ketzerisch war und
dann würde sie eins zu jetzt im jetzigen
pflaster hotel in paris genommen und
würde verbrannt also vielleicht jetzt
kurz daran denken wie schlimm das also
nicht nur ken direkt sondern lebens in
flammen verbrannt also wirklich sehr
schnell
ok und was interessant ist ist dass sie
sie hatte mehrmals die gelegenheit von
ihrer lehre zurück zu treten und sagen
okay ich sage ich mache das nicht wieder
ich schreibe das nicht wieder euren
stattdessen hat sie über mehr als ein
jahr im gefängnis als sie sich geweigert
überhaupt mit dem inquisitor überhaupt
in dem prozess teilzunehmen hat sich
nicht hat nicht versucht sich zu
verteidigen
im gegensatz zu die italienische
nationalmannschaft wochen hat
hat wirklich nur stur gesagt ich trete
von meiner lehre nicht zurück und
vielleicht nur deswegen lohnt es sich da
rein zu schauen was diese lehre war es
den 1940 er wäre die antwort also wenn
wir uns fragen okay was hat sie gelehrt
was so alles was schlimm wäre die
antwort nur dass wir ich glaub 12 sätze
in dem prozess selbst haben aus dem buch
genommen und wir hätten diese zwölf
sätze lesen können und das wäre es also
wir hatten das buch nicht aber dann
würde es entdeckt dass ein anonymes berg
was schon im 14 jahrhundert relativ weit
verbreitet war nahmen spiegelte
einfachen zählen das ist das buch voraus
woraus zum teil die thesen genommen
werden würden es gibt zwei auf der liste
stehen die in dem buch zu finden sind
und eine forscherin
das war eine vorstellung hat entdeckt
dass dieses buch was wir schon kannte
ein anonymes buch doch das buch von
margaretha ist also riesig wie sie
überraschung
es gibt mehrere fassungen dieses buches
ist wie gesagt das heißt die rolle des
amtlich ist nicht sehr gut tut mir leid
und die ich habe den französischen titel
angegeben weil das buch auf französisch
geschrieben wurde
allerdings ist die alte französische
fassung jetzt verloren was wir haben
sind drei verschiedene mittelalterliche
fassungen davon
das buch aufwand so es ist aber ein
mitglied französisch ist jemand hier ein
französischer experte
ok falls sie alle fragen haben was die
unterschiede sind inzwischen alle
französischen mittel französisch sie
finden
sich an sie wenden es ist anders sein
als der von dem beispiel englisch können
wir vielleicht entnehmen zum beispiel
chance lesen 64 zu lesen ist relativ
leicht relativ chancenlos gewesen
der wolf zu lesen für gis es ja also wir
sehen dass diese diese nicht lateinische
diese volksgarten
im mittel werden des mittelalters haben
sich relativ viel entwickelt ich weiß
übrigens dass shakespeare nicht möglich
ist und das ist der fall mit französisch
also ich glaube es sogar natürlich als
franzose ist nicht als ob das auch
einmal 330 150 alle alsbald französisch
sprechen und dann ab januar erster
januar jetzt so jetzt zeigen wir mittel
fand das ist natürlich eine eine
langsame der campari jeden fall
wir haben eine mittel französische
übersetzung davon eine lateinische
übersetzung und eine mittel englische
übersetzte und natürlich würde man davon
ausgehen dass die fassung die nächste
zum am nächsten zur vollständigen
fassung steht werde die mittel
französische übersetzung würde auf basis
der als physischen texterfassung gemacht
aber ich hab' forschung darüber gelesen
die behauptet dass die die französische
übersetzung die wir haben ist irgend ein
bisschen weniger kontrovers als das was
wir in der englischen könnten und es
kann sein dass die französische
übersetzung ein bisschen geeinigt ist
vom problematischen stellen
das ist nicht unwichtig ist klingt ein
bisschen langweilig für uns alles nicht
unwichtig weil die übersetzungen die
verfügung stehen
für uns immer in die moderne
übersetzungen die wir wahrscheinlich
lesen wollen
die sind alle auf basis der mittel
französischen fassung also die sind
weniger problematisch als was man das
was man vielleicht in der englischen der
mit leidlichen englischen fassung
bringen könnte zum glück ist das was wir
in dieser fassung finden sehr kontrovers
also wir haben keinen keiner kein mangel
an
schockierende und lehre das buch also
allein anhand dieser drei übersetzungen
können wir vielleicht schon vermuten
dass das buch relativ einflussreich war
und das stimmt ein harz beispiel ist
dass mehrere meister eckhart forscher
sieg einen wahrscheinlichen meister
eckhart produkte deutscher mystiker vom
zehnten jahrhundert bis 14 jahrhundert
her irgendwie so sein kompromiss
zwischen den klassikern und jemand wie
margareta weil sie ist wirklich eine
musikerin die auf volkssprache schweiz
ist völlig außerhalb der universitäts
kultur meister eckarts scheitern
volkssprache predigten auf deutsch ist
auch mystiker ist kritisch gegenüber der
hauptstrom der philosophie mittelalter
würde aber auch das klassisch
ausgebildet gehört das elend amerikanern
also von daher ist es können wir es
gleich sagen es gibt ein kontinuum von
jemandem wie des coaches zu jemand wie
margarete über jemand wie die meister
eckhart die also die idee ist die wir
finden ist dass manche von ihnen lernen
vielleicht bei meister eckhart
auftauchen das ist noch mal kontrovers
sie sind berg hat und sie sind übrigens
zeitgenosse genossen also es könnte sein
das nochmal eine offene frage die
mittelalterliche denker mit dem sie am
häufigsten verglichen wird es ist
natürlich nichts gutes oder sogar
meister eckhart sondern die zwei
denkerinnen die wir gerade beschlossen
haben nämlich hd enthält vor allem diese
diese idee dass margarete auch eine
beginne war würde dann natürlich dieses
vergleich unterstützen also die und oft
hat man den eintrag okay wir haben diese
drei denkerinnen diesen alle begins
beginnen mystik und wie gesagt ist das
ist leider ist nicht ganz klar
ich beginne war oder nicht aber das war
gleich ist es so oder so ist bei der es
gerechtfertigt erstens die party und
märkte schreibt sie in volkssprache und
natürlich ist das bis diese zeit also
früh vierzehnter jahrhundert das ist
wirklich keine wir können sagen das ist
so das ist die zeit burg sprache
wirklich in das intellektuelle leben des
mittelalters ein kommt paradebeispiel
ist natürlich dante die deutliche
komödie würden auch in diesen
jahrzehnten geschrieben und von daher
könnte man sie mit vielen figuren der
mitfahren der mittel als ich in mystic
vergleichen
und vielleicht könnte man dann den
eindruck haben auch wir vergleichen sie
mit harten metal weil alle drei frauen
waren und sie wissen schon was ich von
dieser von dieser begründen halten würde
ich würde das war nicht schlecht sie
will keinen halt
aber es gibt andere gemeinsamkeiten
zwischen auf der einen seite margareta
und auf der anderen seite
halle-wittenberg hält vor allem nimmt
sie auch literarische ideen und trocken
außenminister die dass das buch ist so
konstruiert aber ab und zu gibt es dann
gibt es immer gedichte das hauptsächlich
prosa müssen nochmal das haben welche
und mehrmals gesehen oder also dieses
diese kombinieren von prosa und gedichte
okay erstens dass ein paar 2
nach einem vorwort steigt sie in einen
dialog zwischen mehreren alle
allegorischen figuren
es gibt eigentlich es gibt viele die
vorkommen die meisten kommen sehr kurz
vorher sind wir haben nur eine kurze
rede also zum beispiel die wahrheit
spricht irgendwann aber nur ein
paragraph die hauptdarsteller ist
sozusagen die habt alle gebäude figuren
sind seele liebe und vernunft und und
sofort erkennen wir ein topos aus - also
klassisch minnesang haben wir sehr oft
diese idee okay wir haben der liebhaber
und er ist zwischen liebe und vernunft
gerissen weil die liebe sagt er muss
unbedingt die geliebte dann erobern oder
für sich gewinnen mindestens unvernunft
sagt dass es als unvernünftig liebe ist
ist emotionen durchaus liebe nicht
folgen weil das bringt dich in
schwierigkeiten die wir schmerz erleben
du wirst nach die gelebte immer
nachsehen müssen
tu es nicht und vernunft und liebe
halten dann regen gegeneinander das ist
klassisch - an dann ein sehr gutes
beispiel in einem text den ich schon
mehrmals erwähnt habe in den letzten
wochen ist sogar an der horse
wohlgemerkt auch auf französisch
geschrieben und vielleicht 20 jahre
davor also mehr oder länger aus der
gleichen zeit
und dort haben wir genau solche szenen
also haben sehen wo der liebhaber zuerst
mit vernunft und der für natur liebe zu
seinen vorlieben vor sich hin
sie geben vor liebe aber die liebe kommt
jemand sagt nein du gehörst mir und der
liebhaber deals dann er wird sogar der
untertan der der liebe also wie eine
mittelalterliche beziehung zwischen herr
und untertan und mehr oder weniger das
gleiche passiert hier obwohl die dritte
person im spiel ist kein liebhaber
sondern seele
die serie wird nichts als margarete
ausdrücklich identifiziert aber das
scheint die idee so sein
also wir haben margareta seele und sie
ist man man würde erwarten sie es
zwischen liebe und vernunft gerissen
interessanterweise scheint vernunft mehr
oder mendiger solistische theologie und
philosophie zu sein
liebe ist dann die mystischen lehre die
sie dann in dem buch darstellen und
verteidigen will und man muss schon
sagen dass von hin- und hergerissen ist
eigentlich wenig rede
in dem buch in dem spiegel
denn der digitale scheint von anfang an
mehr oder weniger schon von liebe
überzeugt zu sein und diesen so sein
depot aktionen versuchen zusammen
vernunft einzureden zu sehen dass sie
das bessere verständnis haben
also manchmal geht das sagen dass
margareta irgendwie implizit ihre eigene
seele schon für befreit erklärt
vielleicht liegt es daran dass das buch
aus der perspektive geschrieben wird von
einer serie die schon mystische
erfahrung genossen hat und deswegen kann
es kann die seele schon aus eigener
erfahrung sagen dass die vernunft doch
nicht recht hat
liebe hat recht die fertige begann es
natürlich erklären was was liebe
behauptet und was versuche jetzt nur
sehr klein wie das buch sich liest
übrigens noch mal reden es gibt heraus
züge des textes durch die website
verfügbar
also wenn sie da hierzu meine meinberg
veranstaltungen gehen
es gibt nicht nur die handys von jede
woche sondern je einen text für jede
denke dann die wir bestatten
in diesem fall ist die übersetzung die
zur verfügung hatte eine englische
übersetzung aber gibt es ironisch den
text für nächste woche wurde auf
englisch verfasst ist von julian fern
aber dafür habe ich eine deutsche
übersetzung okay es gibt wahrscheinlich
eine pflanze sind text in der bibliothek
wenn sie das lesen wollen
wenn sie das lesen können ja gesagt also
grob ist ist die situation liebe von
seele und fern und hat recht in der
bucht also von uns wird besitz von liebe
und mit mit hilfe der seele
dann kommen andere
personen beim zum beispiel die wahrheit
die tugend gnade oder was auch immer die
kommen da kommen mehrere jahre vor ich
sagen was kurz ist dann verschwinden
jetzt haben wir es kennen können wir
eine ironische beobachtung machen
nämlich das von den texten die wir schon
besprochen haben also wenn wir an helga
denken hd bridge und und mechthild sie
haben wahrscheinlich schon bemerkt
gemerkt dass das diese werke definitiv
nicht so lesen wie philosophische werke
sind keine fälle so wild tat
man könnte sogar sagen sie sind nichts
sie würden nicht so geschrieben dass sie
ein versuch bilden irgendwelche
philosophie thesen zu verteidigen oder
zu äußern und dann dafür dafür ist
argumentieren dass das ist eine art
videotext und es mehr wie vielleicht
also ließ sich mehr die literatur
eigentlich oder spirituelle literatur
was ich bisher einmal machen musste weil
sozusagen implizite philosophische
thesen rauszunehmen und diese thesen
ihnen zu präsentieren
jetzt haben wir die situation wo wir
einen text haben der aus gebieten die
vernunft dann also wirklich nicht nur
als eingeschränkt zurück weiß sondern
wirklich kritisiert und nicht akzeptiert
dass er von und ist hier wirklich nur da
und korrigiert zu werden
trotzdem liest dieser text sich vielmehr
wie ein philosophischer tat also wie es
war vielleicht nicht die erste
beschreibung die man einfahren würde
beim lesen also wie gesagt
ein minister von äußeren gestalt her
aber was wirklich klar ist ist das liebe
und auch die seele
sie vertreten mehrere kontroverse thesen
die vernunft an unvernunft versucht
diese diese thesen zu unterminieren und
kann das nicht machen also liebe gewinnt
immer mit ihren argumenten ist ähnlich
wie in roman della rossa es auch mehr
ein philosophisches geschmack hat
sozusagen vom lesen her und was wirklich
was wirklich spannend ist ist das wie
gesagt vernunft sehr sich ausdrücklich
und sehr eng in verbindung gebracht wird
mit der welt der politischen theologie
und philosophie zum beispiel haben gibt
es wie gesagt eine vorwort und in diesem
vorwurf sagt sie
theologen und gelehrte werden diese
schrift nie verstehen folge liebe und
glaube da hin wo vernunft nicht hinkommt
sie sagt auch zum beispiel das können
und ein auge ist also das heißt
natürlich nicht dass wir uns blenden
lässt aber ist sehr beschränkt
vom sehen her fern und ist jetzt alles
in einer beschränkten weise ein
und das muss immer korrigiert werden man
könnte das vielleicht mit der
einstellung der von ihm gegenüber das
ist jetzt wirklich ironisch die wir halt
bei den europa- vermissten gefunden
haben weil ihre westen die waren reine
philosophen die waren sozusagen
beruflicher dass die techniker und um
die möglichkeit zu sichern dass sie
unabhängig und völlig ungestört
philosophie treiben konnten
haben sie gesagt 'ja ja natürlich machen
wir das alles nur als philosophen netz
natur vernunft und theologie kommt und
sagt das ist alles falsch
nehmen wir das einfach zu kein problem
also diese idee dass das von uns so
eingeschränkt ist dass man das
irgendwann am ende einfach loslassen
muss was thomas natürlich so unangenehm
war
interessanterweise finden wir dass bei
den diese beiden diesen ganz radikalen
erwarten
das war hier versuchen dann vorzeichen
zu vermeiden und das finden wir auch in
dieser mister ken mit margareta also das
finde ich sehr interessant und etwas was
hier auch vielleicht wichtig zu bemerken
ist ist das margareta eine chance zu
geben will
dass ihr buch als geschriebenes werk
irgendwie eine ähnliche rolle hat wie
die von awp
das heißt fünf und ist vielleicht eine
kein vermittler die uns näher zu gott
bringt aber nicht nicht vollständig
nicht denkt nicht so gut wie vollständig
fertig reisen kann so sagen oder
vollziehen kann und ähnlicher weise hat
margarete anscheinend die idee dass ihr
buch als buch nur ein vermittler ist
zwischen ihr oder vielleicht zwischen
dem leser und gott also du kannst nichts
einheit mit gott erreichen durchlesen
du kannst nur einheit mit gott erreichen
durch liebe für gott wie wir sein werden
und man könnte deswegen sagen dass der
dass das buch nur ein wegweiser ist in
die richtige richtung
das ist natürlich ein ist eigentlich
sehr häufige einstellung die wir oft
investors es muss finden das ist
natürlich dass das paradox an mystischen
schriften dass sie versuchen was zu
beschreiben
oder weil ihnen das in worten nicht
vollständig äußert werden kann und das
repräsentiert margareta mit einem
vergleich ganz am anfang des textes
das ist übrigens noch ein fall wo sie
ein topos aus vorherigen literatur nimmt
sie sie hat eine eine literarische
quelle über alexander der große und es
gibt eine legende in dieser quelle wo
eine frau von alexander herz und wird in
ihn verliebt ohne ihnen kennen gelernt
zu haben und die frau lässt ein gemälde
machen
von ihm und hat dann liebe für alexander
durch dieses band und margareta
vergleicht ihr buch mit diesem geld also
natürlich ist gott gott spielt die rolle
von alexander der große csd verliebte
dame und das buch das das ist die
gemälde das kommt ganz am anfang des
textes
das übrigens auch zu der zu ihrer
einstellung aus autoren ist ich wollte
wird noch was sagen sie zu der frage ob
sie so seien die seele ist von den drei
hauptfiguren
weil also irgendwie ist lautet die
antwort ja
aber irgendwie hat sich antwort nein es
war deswegen weil liebe liebe bietet der
also es gibt diese zwei personen von
universal liebe scheint der säle im
voraus zu sein hat tieferes verständnis
als die seele und bringt uns also die
seele ist eigentlich auf der seite von
liebe gegen vernunft aber versteht die
lehre der liebling nicht vollständig und
deswegen vernunft
kritische fragen liebe gegenüber und
dieselbe stadt immer fragen mehr
aus dem grund weil es dass sie mehr
verstehen will was die liebe dann
erkennt und das heißt dass margareta als
autor natürlich als autorin schreibt
margarete die texte für liebe seele
unvernunft als sie es gleichzeitig
identisch mit celle und nicht identisch
weil sie auch identisches mit liebe und
vielleicht sogar spielt die rolle von
vernunft und dieses spielchen ist was
das wir dass wir auch in anderen werken
waren der volkswagen literatur dieser
zeit finden
denken wir an dante noch mal sie haben
natürlich alle den die göttliche komödie
gelesen wenn nicht heute abend fanden
sie an die glückliche versprochen also
jeder von uns könnte jederzeit sterben
und die sterben zu haben ohne die
göttliche komödie gewesen zu haben das
öl zu den schlimmsten schlimmsten sachen
die die jemanden passieren kann
tut mir leid aber es ist so also da bin
ich ganz durch also ich nehme es wie es
kommt aber wenn ich sterbe ich werde
mindestens sagen können wir haben
mindestens ig medien gelesen und der
plattform
sie haben aber fast alle von ihnen haben
wahrscheinlich schon mindestens
teilweise die göttliche komödie gelesen
deswegen wissen sie dass der hauptfigur
durch die ganze kurve ist dante aber er
beschreibt seine reise durch rektor und
semmel oder paradies
und er beschreibt sich selbst als
zusammentun wissen
reisende aus der perspektive von einem
autor der das angeblich schon alles
erlebt hat
also er ist es gibt ein distanz zwischen
ihm und ihm also dante der autor und
dante der der figur in der kälte panov
tinte mindestens in der
englischsprachigen literatur leben sie
die wegen die forscher von der pilgrim
enterprise und zwischen diesen zwei
dante ist zu unterscheiden
oder denken wir auch ein roman der rost
noch mal also meine zwei lieblings
vergleiche für margarita
da haben wir der liebt den liebhaber in
gedicht und der liebhaber wird am anfang
ausdrücklich gesagt die träumt erfassung
des dichters zu sein also erträumt dass
er ein liebhaber es gesundheit der in
einer hose geliebt qualit ist und dann
geschieht all die sachen und nochmal ist
ist er gleichzeitig der liebhaber
innerhalb der funktion und der autor
ähnlicher weise hier
wir eine gewisse distanz zwischen
margareta und margareta und sie markiert
diese distanz dadurch dass sie sich
selbst nennt übrigens haben wir wenn es
auch nächste woche sehen mit julian weil
sie erklärt ihre eigene mystische
erfahrungen im nachhinein und ist
deswegen diejenige die sieht in den
beschreibungen von den erfahrungen und
es auch diejenige die erklärt was das
alles bedeutet wie auch bei hildegard
soviel zum buch und gestalt des buches
[Musik]
oder als gruppe glaube ich also ich hab
gesehen dass jemand das als opa geführt
hat aber es könnte man durchaus man das
ist das weiß ich nicht das könnte sein
wie man es liest sich wie ein
katholischer dialog und deswegen wie ein
theaterstück also die theologen hatten
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwas mit
griechischen theater zu tun aber es ist
wirklich genauso also liebe ist sagt
versagten also jetzt könnte man
vielleicht sollten wir das machen ja in
der lenkung
es könnte sein ich habe nicht gelesen
dass das im mittelalter als theaterstück
geführt würde ich aber ich habe schon
gesehen dass das als opa dann
installiert würde interessante häuser
[Applaus]
wir haben schon gesehen dass sie relativ
gut ist sie sogar sehr kritisch der von
und gegenüber und das hängt damit
zusammen was sie über die tuben sagt und
ich glaube wenn man nur eine these von
margarita cans oder kennen sollte dann
dann diese die folgende these über die
tugend sie ist sie würde dafür zum teil
verurteilt war als sie behauptet hat
dass die befreite oder reine seele die
tugend nicht mehr braucht also und haben
was was zitiert würde in dem prozess war
ein satz wie sie sagt die serie hat
keinen keinen nutzen aus tugend und
gnade
das kann ich verstehen warum das kreuz
als ketzerisch verurteilt wurde
ich habe übrigens denkt hat den auszug
was ich in der haft der website getan
habe das fängt damit an mit den kapiteln
wo sie diese these über die tugend
zuerst äußert und ähnlicher weise wie
das was sie bei dem was ich über die
vernunft gesagt habe ist es nicht so
dass sie behaupten will dass die tugend
völlig nutzlos sind würde dass sie
nichts wert sind sondern behauptet sie
dass die tugend nur ein weg bildet um
gott zu erreichen aber nur ein teil des
weges und das kann man so sagen
überschreiten und jenseits der tugend
konnten sie ist das ist der typische von
ihr dass sie immer diese
boxerische formulierungen trifft und sie
sagt dass diese die die touren nicht
mehr nutzt ist tugendhafter als die
jugendliche seele und irgendwas zu
verstehen müssen wir zuerst über ihr
vielleicht und man kann man kann sogar
sagen dass sie wahrscheinlich in der
akademischen tradition er steht ja ja
würde ich auch sagen dir mein mann sagt
ähnliche sachen wie also ist sie sagt du
kannst machen was du willst aber es ist
sagt mehr haben diese serie wird gar
nichts machen zum beispiel sagt sogar
die die diese reine seele
macht nichts so gar nichts für gott
sondern ruht in gott oder ist mit gott
verein hält das ist ja ähnlich
wir sehen rechts glaube ich also aber um
mir das wirklich zu verstehen müssen wir
zuerst nachfragen was sie unter tugend
hier versteht und aus der kritik die sie
gegen die truhen äußert scheint es dass
sie vorwiegend nichts an zb
aristotelische tugend denkt sondern mehr
wie askese und so hat die also dieses
leben was mehrere heilige dann genäht
haben sie sagt implizit zwischendurch
dass sie das aus also die seele sagt
dass sie dass sie selbst fast gestorben
an diese diese art von leben ist also es
scheint dass sie auch selber zu sagen es
käse ausprobiert hat und entdeckt hat
dass das nichts bringt
oder wenn vielleicht nicht aber hat
nicht das gebracht was sie wirklich
wollte nämlich
vereinigung mit gott und sie ist
wirklich sehr sehr kritisch gegen diese
ästhetik sie sagt das sind leute die
praktisch dann sie sind damit zufrieden
dass sie so tugendhaft leben oder sie
denken nicht daran dass thun ableben nur
ein mittel ist um einen weiteren zweck
zu erreichen und sie also wie bei der
vernunft gibt sie zu dass das irgendwie
wertvoll ist habe nur als mittel und im
vergleich zu den besten zustand was wir
gleich wovon wir gleich hören werden
ist das wirklich gar nichts sie es gibt
es gibt viele schöne metapher und
vergleiche in dem text und ein lieblings
vergleich von mir ist sie sagt derjenige
der mit der tugend zufrieden ist ist wie
die nachteile die denkt dass ihr die
kinder die schönste vögel sind wir haben
nichts gegen nachahmer die die idee ist
dass sie sehr düster und nicht also es
gibt handel füllen die viel viel schöner
sind aber weil es diese mutterrolle
denkt aber meine kinder es ist das beste
was es gibt ähnliche weise ist derjenige
der durch die tugend lebt ist jemand der
mit zu wenig zufrieden ist können wir
sagen dann definiert sie eine andere art
person die auch tugendhaft lebt aber
irgendwie sport dass es mehr geben
könnte und ist text regen immer
unzufrieden das war vielleicht jede
vorherige situation und um jenseits
dieser ist etwas hinzukommen muss man
und jetzt kommt die zweite berühmte
these von margaretha die mit der ersten
zusammenhängt muss man die vernichtung
des selbst erreichen
okay was heißt das ich denke die der
beste weg das zu verstehen ist durch
eine sehr christliche idee nämlich
bescheidenheit
sie sagt dass die mutter der truman die
der anderen tugend ist bescheidenheit
also alle anderen
und übrigens das klingt auch ein
bisschen wie augustinus dass diese idee
bescheidenheit ist also erst caritas
lustig weil er alle anderen tun aber die
idee ist so ähnlich könnte man sagen und
bescheidenheit ist das was zu sagen
hinter der anderen tugend steckt man ist
und diese besser einfach bescheiden zu
sein als zum beispiel tapfer oder frauen
oder die passauer zu sein oder
selbstbeherrschung zu erreichen
also für mich ist das alles
das erinnert sehr an dem was wir noch
mal bei nationalismus finden genau wie
ich letzte woche gesagt habe bei den
beginn vor allem bei proteinen der auch
behaupten will dass man die tugend als
sozusagen eine eine vorstufe der
philosophen entwicklung verstehen müssen
also man fängt sozusagen mit der tugend
an aber bleibt nicht und innerhalb der
der politischen tuns nennt so seien
jugendliche handlung in dieser welt das
ist okay aber es ist sehr niedrige stufe
der vollkommenheit wirklich vollkommen
ist wenn man einigung mit den
spirituellen ursachen erreicht und es
genauso wie das genauso bei margareta
dann aber in einer anderen art und weise
als bei platin für kloten
ist die vollkommenheit jenseits der
tugend intellektuelles verständnis für
seine reformen
für sie ist die ist der zustand jenseits
der tu und wie gesagt vernunft
vernichtung und bescheidenheit was heißt
dass das heißt du musst akzeptieren dass
du nicht bist und der die begründung die
sie dafür gibt ist das als geschaffenes
denn du sowieso immer nichts war im
vergleich zu gott
also er ist unbegrenztes sein können wir
sagen wir sind begrenzt und deswegen im
vergleich zu ihnen sind wir die nichts
und die und das ist die bescheidenheit
von wem sie spricht das ist eigentlich
eine eigentlich eine philosophische
verstellung also wenn man sie ernst
nimmt dass gott unendlich und logisch
oder wette physisch von uns überlegen
ist dann sind müssen wir zugeben dass
wir im vergleich zu ihnen gar nichts
also gar kein sein
besitzen sie verfolgt diese idee und
dann und akzeptiert am ende dass die
seele wirklich gar nichts ist und
deswegen ist sie so bescheiden also es
gibt nichts bescheidene also sagen ich
bin nicht okay ich glaube das was ich
gerade gesagt habe das irgendwie richtig
aber es ist nicht die art und weise wie
sie des austritts sie drücken und das
übrigens ist nochmals nach einer
christines sie drückt ist vielmehr eine
in der art und weise aus wo sie sagt
dass das der selbst den vernichten
vernichtet werden muss ist die villa
wenn also die vernichtung für sie heißt
keine wille mehr zu haben die von der
wille gottes unterschieden oder
unterschiedlich christ und deswegen
nimmt sie auf diesen tafeln herr wie mit
dass die welle verschmelzt in der wille
gottes oder verschwendet einmal sagt sie
dass die menschliche wille ist wie eine
eine kerzenflamme die in einer großen
flamme dann auflöst
also eine größere ein größeres feuer
dass unser kleines feuer ist irgendwie
schlapp für sie es nochmal paradox diese
unsere welt völlig abzugeben ist die
absolute freiheit weil wenn wir mit
unseren eigenen welt leben wir nur
unsere wünsche und unsere eingeschränkte
zwecke verfolgen wenn wir keine zwecke
mehr haben die wirklich uns gehören
sondern nur die relais gottes susan für
unsere welle übernehmen dann haben wir
wie sie sagt freiheit von uns selbst
oder die freiheit nichts zu wollen
interessanterweise und als das fand ich
es wirklich sehr philosophisch zu sein
sie sagt in einer passage dass diese
diese reine oder befreite fälle oder
seele
das besteht nicht nur darin dass du
nicht willst nicht willst sondern dass
du auch nicht du willst auch nicht
wollen
also wir die heutzutage würden wir sagen
es gibt erste und zweite ordnung wollen
zum beispiel ich wünsche dass ich mit
zigaretten rauchen aufhören könnte ich
war wichtig für uns zu sagen beispiel
und dann habe ich den wunsch nichts mehr
zigaretten zu wollen und ähnlicher weise
sagt sie hier
die ist nicht nur das nicht nichts welt
nicht stellen will auch nichts wollen
also diese zweite ordnung
wenn ist auch verschwunden das es
übrigens ein beispiel wo vernunft und
dagegen argumentiert man sagt das ist
unmöglich
du kannst nicht wählen wollen
das ist eine fülle verschwindet und sie
sagt doch also du kannst du erstmal
wollen dass deine wille verschwindet und
dann kannst du das erreichen und dann
ist eine welle weg und dann bist du
vernichtet das was ich hier wirklich
sehr interessant finde ist unter anderem
dass mein wir denken an mutter hatte ihn
lustig und denken herr okay die die
regen himmel von einigung mit gott und
vernichtung bla bla bla bla
das hat nichts mit fluss wie zu tun aber
das ist wirklich eine theorie tabelle
und ist wirklich eine reaktion auf
andere mittelalterliche augustin ische
ansichten über die welle ist zum
beispiel sie sagt in einer passage dass
gott
obwohl gott so unendlich ist an und kann
gott es nicht guckt uns nicht dazu
bringen dass wir in dieser art und weise
vernichten weil gott uns beispiel nicht
wie viele gegeben hat und was er uns
gegeben hat war eine freie wille und das
heißt dass er uns eine entscheidung eine
ein entscheidungs vermögen gegeben hat
was er nicht wieder wegnehmen kann nur
wir können können entscheiden nichts
mehr zu entscheiden oder nur wir können
wollen nichts mehr als zu wollen
anders gesagt nur und wir können sogar
eigene fälle einsetzen damit diese will
ist sich selbst vernichtet und deswegen
kannst du es auch ich glaube die ein
bisschen von anderen mystikerinnen die
wir besprechen von wissen sie von hin
ein bisschen unterscheiden weil für sie
ist das überhaupt nichts passt dass kein
passives prozess
du musst mich dran arbeiten und
versuchen deine seele zu vernichten
kein warten dass gott auftauchen wie
julian zb machen jetzt wie wir sagen wir
sehen werden ja hab ich auch gedacht
nein natürlich nicht ist die antwort
aber das erinnert sehr an buddhismus
also diese idee dass die zusagen die
befreiung von sich selbst hat
irgendetwas damit zu tun dass man die
die villa aufgeben muss das in zellen
buddhismus aber ich würde sagen dass
fehlende eine gegenreaktion gegen die
zeit siege oder zeitgenössische
klassische theorien dass eigentlich das
nächste was ich sagen wollte
lassen sie mich überzeugen und dann
können sie lang auf fragen
die also wenn man zum beispiel an thomas
von aquin denkt was ist seine ethische
lehre also kurzum haben wir alle
sehnsucht nach dem guten und wir haben
diese welle das gute so haben und die
diese welle wird nur so sagen ab
vollständig genutzt oder befriedigt
dadurch dass wir das größte gute
erreichen das ist gott also für ihn ist
die ästhetik wirklich an die
befriedigung der wille durch nähe zu
gott das können wir in diesem leben
nicht erreichen
das können wir nur im nachleben
erreichen und sie argumentiert lag
natürlich nicht direkt gegen thomas also
ihr habt das sie unbedingt tonfalls
gelesen hat wahrscheinlich eher nichts
sie aber sie argumentiert dass man
stattdessen einfach aufgeben soll dass
man die will ich überhaupt eins setzt
weil die also diese art und weise gott
zu erreichen ist irgendwie immer eigen
also ist zuviel aufdeckt die die das
eigene gute konzipiert was wir machen
sondern um unsere eigene gute aufzugeben
und nur gott also in gott zu
verschmelzen
aber ich muss zugeben das ist wirklich
an buddhismus er hat mich auch daran
erinnert es gibt es gibt grundlegende
philosophische ideen mein
lieblingsbeispiel des atheismus
es gibt artemis müsse zum beispiel
indien im islam und im als blosse wie
und wo islamische denke natürlich
zuschuss oder zugang auf geschirr texte
hatten scheint atheismus eine
unabhängige entwicklung innerhalb des
islam zu sein und auch innerhalb der
indischen tradition
ich denke wenn du anfängst zu überlegen
was den körper kommst du auf optimismus
dass wir einfach passieren wenn du
überlegst ok habe eine welle wie kann
ich wie kann ich befriedigung erreichen
offensichtliche antwort gibt eine welle
auf und sie ist sie ist das beste
beispiel dass sie keine aus mittelalter
ist auch sehr storage vielleicht wobei
die story kann ich sagen würde dass man
die typen aufgeben sollte apfel programm
übrigens nächste woche werde ich julian
von deutsch zu sprechen als zusammenhang
werde ich was allgemeines zu englische
mystik und als polizisten der zeit von
juli an sagen eigentlich ein text namens
dekade
mit julian sind wir ein bisschen mehr
wie beide weit bei texten die uns
vielleicht mehr an hd bridge und
margaret und erzählt rennen also sehr
starke mystische erfahrungen aber einen
vergleich aber also jetzt wird es nicht
um sex gehen sondern um gewalt weil die
die mystische erfahrungen die sie hatten
hatten sehr viel mit blut und ist leiden
dass jesus zu tun
das ist wirklich sehr also wirklich
gruselig es ist mel gibson christentum
rechtfertige aber genau wie hildegard
zum beispiel bietet sie dann ihre eigene
auslegung der bedeutung diesen
mystischen diese mystische erfahrung
sie ist mehrere generationen später als
marietta also nächste woche sind wir
wirklich mitten im 14 jahrhundert
dankeschön